JOHN SULLIVAN SERVED AS THE
U.S. AMBASSADOR TO RUSSIA.
HE WAS THERE WHEN VLADIMIR
PUTIN LOST THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
AMBASSADOR, WELCOME BACK TO THE
PROGRAM.
YOU ARE IN WASHINGTON, THIS
CHAOS IS I WRAPPED-ING IN
CONGRESS AS WE SPEAK.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, DOES THIS
THREATEN AMERICA'S STANDING AND
WHAT MAGIC DOES IT GAVE WHEN
THE U.S. IS TRYING TO PROJECT
STRENGTH IN SUPPORT OF UKRAINE?
THEY ARE AGAINST RUSSIA.
>> IT IS GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
IT IS ONE THAT I STRUGGLED WITH
WHEN I WAS THE AMBASSADOR IN
MOSCOW.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE EVENTS ON
JANUARY SIX WERE LIKE CATNIP
FOR THE RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
SOCIETY.
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF THE
KREMLIN.
THEY PAID VERY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
WASHINGTON.
THEY USED THE GEORGE FLOYD
PROTEST THEIR ADVANTAGE ON
JANUARY 6TH.
I AM NOT SURE THAT THE VOTES
FOR SPEAKER RISE TO THAT LEVEL.
I'M --
THERE WAS THE PROPAGANDA USED
AGAINST US AT EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
>> THAT IS PRETTY MUCH SECURE.
THAT DOESN'T EXPIRE.
IT DOES NOT NEED ANOTHER
MANDATE UNTIL SEPTEMBER.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
THAT IS RIGHT.
WE HAVE THE WARNINGS FROM THE
PRESIDENT SPEND IT
APPROPRIATELY.
THAT IS TERRIFIC.
>> PUT THAT HAT ON AND TAKE US
INTO THE KREMLIN.
YOU WERE THERE IN MOSCOW.
AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE HAD BEEN
PREDICTING FOR A LONG TIME THAT
THE RUSSIANS WERE GOING TO
INVADE.
WERE YOU SEEING THAT?
WERE YOU FEELING THAT BACK TO
THE U.S. FROM RUSSIA?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, NOT ONLY
THE INTELLIGENCE THAT I WAS
RECEIVING, BUT THERE IS THIS
PROBABLE FEEL.
THEY WERE CONFIDENT ABOUT HOW
THEY WERE HANDLING THIS PROBLEM
IN UKRAINE.
WE THINK IT IS A MATTER OF
FOREIGN POLICY.
THAT'S PART OF U.S. DOMESTIC
POLICY.
IT IS PART OF THEIR IDEA OF
THIS RUSSIAN IMPERIAL AND THE
THAT THEY ARE CULTIVATING.
I BEFORE FEBRUARY 24TH, THERE
WAS INFORMATION THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN WAS GOING TO LAUNCH A
LARGE-SCALE INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
I SAID THAT PUBLICLY AT ANY
EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
>> ARE YOU CONVINCED OF WHAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS NOW
TELLING THE WORLD?
HE ADDRESSED A JOINT MEETING OF
CONGRESS.
THEY BELIEVE I --
>> HAVE NOT GIVEN UP DESPITE
BATTLEFIELD LOSSES ON THE BIG
PROJECT I.
THEY MAY BE WANTING ANOTHER GO
IN KYIV AND ELSEWHERE.
DO YOU THINK, GIVEN WHAT HAS
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST TEN
MONTHS OF THE WAR, DID VLADIMIR
PUTIN STILL HOLD THOSE
AMBITIONS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE HAD THE WHEREWITHAL TO
ACHIEVE IT.
I >> IT HAD BEEN LONG STATED BY
HIM.
I IT IS A PASSION OF HIS.
IT GOES TO HIS WHOLE IDEA OF
HIS ROLE AS THE GATHERER OF
RUSSIAN PLANT.
OF COURSE THIS IS STILL HIS
AMBITION.
THERE IS ALL OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT LOSS THAT THEY HAVE
SUFFERED.
THERE IS THE ABILITY OF THEIR
SECURITY SERVICES TO LOCK THE
TYPE OF --
I --
WILL SUMMON UP THIS WAY, HIS
AMBITION TO TAKE OVER THE
UKRAINE, HE WOULD IF HE COULD.
>> YOU ALSO DEALT WITH THE
FOREIGN MINISTRY.
THAT IS GIVEN OPPOSITION AS THE
AMBASSADOR.
IT HAS BEEN PORTRAYED THAT
PUTIN HAS NO DISSENT.
HE PRETTY MUCH HAS THE SUPPORT
OF EVERYONE IN THE RUSSIAN
SPHERE.
DID YOU FIND THAT WHEN YOU
SPOKE WITH YOUR PEOPLE AT THE
FOREIGN MINISTRY?
THERE WERE ALL OF THESE LOSSES.
I >> WHAT I WOULD SAY, I THEY
WERE IN ENGAGEMENTS AND WHAT
THEY SAID TO ME, THEY WERE.
THEIR BODY LANGUAGE, AT LEAST
FOR SOME OF THEM, THE BODY
LANGUAGE FOR SOME OF THEM
INDICATED TO ME THAT THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT DOUBTS.
OFFICIALS WERE READING FROM
THEIR LOW NOTES.
I WE WERE REVIEWING THE BIDDING
OF WHAT WE THOUGHT THEY WERE
GOING TO DO IN THE UKRAINE.
AS CONVINCED AS I AM OF PUTIN'S
AMBITION FOR THE UKRAINE, I AM
EQUALLY CONVINCED THAT THERE
ARE SENIOR PEOPLE IN THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TODAY.
BOTH FROM BEFORE THE INVASION
AND MORE SIGNIFICANTLY AFTER
THE INVASION.
WE THINK IT WAS A BAD IDEA.
THAT IS A CHANGE IN RUSSIAN
POLICY.
THIS WILL NOT CHANGE PUTIN'S
AMBITION.
>> >> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE NEXT
STEPS I.
WANT TO PLAY THIS FROM THE NEW
YEAR SPEECH.
>> THIS ONE WAS HELD WITH THE
BACKDROP OF THE MILITARY.
HE WENT TO A MILITARY
EMPLACEMENT.
HE SAID THIS, I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THIS, GOES TO THE HEART
OF COMPETING MESSAGES.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> THE LESS LIED ABOUT PEACE,
THEY ARE PREPARING FOR
AGGRESSION.
TODAY, THEY OPENLY ADMITTED IT
WITHOUT SHAME.
THEY CYNICALLY USE UKRAINE AND
ITS PEOPLE WHO WE CAN SPLIT
RUSSIA.
WE HAVE NEVER ALLOWED AND NEVER
WILL ALLOW ANYONE TO DO THIS.
>> AMBASSADOR, THAT IS CLEARLY
NOT AS WHAT HAPPENING.
THE WEST IS NOT ATTACKING
RUSSIA.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN A
REGIME CHANGE.
WOULD YOU SAY THIS IS A FAILURE
OF WESTERN DIPLOMACY AND
MESSAGING THAT SO MUCH OF THE
WORLD, PARTICULARLY THE GLOBAL
SOUTH, THEY ARE IN PUTIN'S CAMP.
THE RUSSIANS ARE.
THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE UNDER
ATTACK.
>> IT IS CERTAINLY
DISAPPOINTING TO ME THAT MORE
COUNTRIES HAVE NOT VOTED WITH
US IN THE U.N. GENERAL
ASSEMBLY.
141 COUNTRIES VOTED IN THE
GENERAL ASSEMBLY.
IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
RESOLUTION, IT IS QUITE STRONG.
IT DEPLORES WHAT THE RUSSIANS
HAVE DONE.
IT DEMANDS THAT THEY REMOVE
THEIR MILITARY FROM THE
UKRAINE.
THE CONTINUED SUPPORT OF
COMMERCIAL ENGAGEMENT FROM
RUSSIA BY OTHER COUNTRIES,
PARTICULARLY DEMOCRACIES, IT IS
DISAPPOINTING.
THIS IS A MOMENT IN HISTORY, I
BELIEVE, IT IS AS SIGNIFICANT
AS SEPTEMBER 1ST, 1939.
PEOPLE MAY SCONE.
THE LAST TIME WE HEARD A
EUROPEAN LEADER USED THAT TYPE
OF LANGUAGE, A NATIONALIST
RHETORIC, HE WAS TRYING TO
JUSTIFY AN AGGRESSIVE WAR.
WE HEARD THAT WHEN ADOLF HITLER,
AFTER SEPTEMBER 1ST, 1939, HE
JUSTIFIED HIS INVASION OF
POLAND.
HE PITTED POLISH BARBARISM
AGAINST ETHNIC GERMANS IN
POLAND BEHIND A PHONY BORDER
BUT HITLER DID NOT RESPECT.
IT WAS DRAWN OUT OF VERSAILLES.
IT IS THE NATIONALIST LANGUAGE.
IT IS SHOCKING.
HE HAS USED IT TO JUSTIFY A
WAR.
THE LIKES OF WHICH HAS NOT BEEN
SEEN ON EUROPEAN CONTINENT IN
77 YEARS.
>> I WANT TO GO TO A FEW ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
PARTICULARLY BY AN EXPERT HERE
IN THE UK.
WE TALK ABOUT THE NEXT BET
STEPS.
ONE OF THEM INVOLVES MESSAGING.
I WANT TO GO THROUGH A FEW
OTHERS.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE WEST IN
THE UNITED STATES IS STILL
PLAYING WITHIN PUTIN'S TERMS?
THIS IS WHAT THEY IMAGINE TO BE
HIS RED LINE.
FOR INSTANCE, THE
ADMINISTRATION KEEPS PUBLICLY
SAYING WHAT IT WILL NOT PROVIDE
THE UKRAINE.
THEY TALK ABOUT HOW FAR THEY
WILL NOT GO.
DO YOU THINK THAT EMBOLDENS
PUTIN?
I THIS IS A SIGN OF UNILATERAL
CONSTRAINT.
HE IS NOT BEING CONSTRAINED.
HE'S BUSY ATTACKING CITIES.
>> THE CAVEAT THAT, AND IT'S A
POWERFUL ARGUMENT, AND I AM
SYMPATHETIC TO IT, THERE IS THE
STRATEGIC AMBIGUITY.
THAT WOULD BE MORE USEFUL FOR
THE UNITED STATES IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE AND OTHERS.
WE ARE DEALING WITH THE ONLY
OTHER NUCLEAR SUPERPOWER ON
EARTH.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CAUTIOUS.
--
PUTIN HAS SIGNALED AND
THREATENED THE USE OF WEAPONS
OF GNATS DESTRUCTION I.
>> --
PUTIN HIMSELF HAS SHOWN HE IS
STRAINED.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS DRAWN SOME
RED LINES.
AS HAS PRESIDENT IZZY.
THE RUSSIAN AND CHINESE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT THEIR UNLIMITED
PARTNERSHIP.
THEY TALK ABOUT HOW THESE GUYS
THE LIMIT ON RUSSIA AND CHINA.
NOT SO.
PRESIDENT XI HAS MADE QUITE
CLEAR THE USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPON
BUT THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION AND
PRESIDENT PUTIN WOULD BE A
NONSTARTER FROM HIS
PERSPECTIVE.
EVEN THERE, PUTIN HAS HEARD
FROM HIS DEAR FRIEND, HIS
COMRADE, PRESIDENT XI, NO NUKES